in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Tony
and Leslie are with us hey guys how are
you hey welcome where do you guys live
Clemmy Missouri all right welcome to
Nashville and here to do your debt-free
scream yes we doubling up a little here
in the summer because we got a lot of
different folks scheduled in and with
our schedules in and out we don't always
have things slotted exactly right and so
my fault but here you are we're glad
you're with us how much have you paid
off
one thousand a hundred and one thousand
dollars very good and how long did that
take you
whoa yeah that's a little quick okay and
range of income during that time we
started out at 70,000 and at our high
point we were making 110 thousand and
that was both of us working three jobs
each whoa so we were definitely a
pounding the pavement you were getting
after it what kind of debt was this
80,000 in student loan debt that I
brought to the marriage and 20,000 in a
home loan okay did you sell anything
major you guys nope and that's 50,000
bucks a year a little better a little
less than that average and so like 4
grand a month you're popping on this you
were right you were living on nothing
and working all the time yeah seven days
a week yeah envelopes I was really
living tightly on small amounts and
these very very small amounts yeah this
is impressive I mean you did this really
fast on that income to debt ratio that's
impressive math very cool
congratulations you guys what tell me
your story what happened 28 months ago
how did you get this fired up well when
we were single we went through a
momentum it was called at our church and
then we got married and we were agreed
on that that was something that was
important to us and we were gonna become
debt-free as soon as we got married
mm-hmm so we started two months after we
got married
okay just been married like 30 months
doesn't have your okay momentum is when
for those of you don't know that 80% of
Church goes through at least 80% goes
through Financial Peace University at
one time and it completely changes the
whole culture of the church doesn't it
yeah everybody starts talking about it
thinking different and everybody gets on
the page and you're all high-fiving each
other with the successes and it's very
cool very fun and that's how you guys
got married in the middle of that hyped
up environment and so you're just like
wow that's cool but then keeping us
around that environment and we were
leading classes together and so that
keeps us accountable so you've been
doing coordinating classes as well oh my
goodness Wow well thank you so much but
congratulations this is I mean you got
great story to tell your class I mean
with what you guys did nobody in your
class is going to be whining you guys
like I don't want to hear it I've been
there I've done I did worse than that
man I'm just wow
well congratulations so how does it feel
to have no debt 30 months into your
marriage it's pretty awesome pretty
often yeah we can actually take a
honeymoon now we can't skip that part
and went straight to the dumping debt
and now we're gonna take a vacation to
Jamaica Jamaica
ah no problem Mon I love it
congratulations you guys are yeah you
live like no one else later you get to
live and give like no one else yeah so
now when you're teaching your class and
they say how did you pay off a hundred
and one thousand in 28 months what do
you tell them the keys are to getting
out of debt oh gosh just stick with it
remain in communication if you have a
partner and the budget definitely doing
that budget and paying with cash it's
definitely a feeling there's envelopes
and you're editing and talking together
about it cutting up those credit cards
and you guys went to work yes he does
yeah if you're really want to get this
done in a short amount of time just keep
working though the income on it so log
on the fire on the income yeah so what
were your parents saying were they like
you to have joined a cult
I know my mom had tried to jump on board
kind of with it but then her husband
didn't come along with her and so she
kind of fell off and so I know they
tried a little bit but but they think
y'all were crazy I mean yeah yeah like
if we would tell them no they were like
why not like why can't you go do this or
why can't you spend money on this well
because we had we're getting out of debt
and so yeah we did get a lot of weird
looks and why are you doing that yeah
but now you kind of have that Toby Keith
moment how you like me now
Jamaica Jamaica I love it that's cool
well congratulations you guys I'm very
very proud of you know we always give
you a copy of Chris Hogan's retire
inspired book signed by him because
that's the next part of the journey
now you're got rid of the baggage and
now you're free to become wealthy and as
you become wealthy you'll a be able to
enjoy it and be change your family tree
see most importantly be outrageously
generous throughout the rest of your
lives and and so that's the purposes of
in God's plan of building wealth and
Chris Hogan will show you how to do that
with retire inspired so very cool let me
ask you one other thing what's the
hardest part of this journey for you
guys probably the constant working seven
days a week and then just having to tell
no to friends yeah what was the worst
job out of all the extra jobs that the
two of you had like the one year like
I'm gonna quit immediately did the
rainbow house yeah I worked for a
non-for-profit for a little bit and it
was just like all-nighters and you have
like children yelling at you and like it
was no fun a bad environment
I don't know if you did know I you know
I didn't really have any bad experiences
it was the best paying part-time job
that you had I would say the best
reporting is we did some pet-sitting huh
that was a lot of fun okay so we made a
great relationship with a couple know
that we still watch their best for now
yeah that's fine
all right very cool well congratulations
Tony and Leslie Columbia Missouri 101
thousand dollars paid off in 28 months
making 70 to 110 count it down let's
hear a debt free scream three two one
I love it I love it I love it I love it
yes very well done you too
very very well done hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show and so you have to
break the cycle you have to flip this
thing on its head and make it behave
you've got to get so fired up and wired
up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind